c'est une terre bénie la plus ancienne
et août touristes viticoles de france
que je vous emmène découvrir aujourd'hui
la route des grands crus de bourgogne
vient de fêter ses 90 ans romanée conti
morceau montrachet
trente trois appellations aussi animé
chante comme prestigieuses que
connaissent bien les vignerons rowling
et les chiens et nous allons rencontrer
aujourd'hui allez je vous embarque la
route des grands crus
[Musique]
chambertin clos de vougeot romanée conti
corton charlemagne montrachet
impossible de citer tous les noms
prestigieux et enchanteur qui borde la
route des grands crus
ces trésors qui font briller les yeux
des amateurs de vins du monde entier
nous allons les découvrir en compagnie
d'un guide passionné aborde une traction
avant datant de l'après-guerre
car la route des grands crus
cet itinéraire mythique de la bourgogne
viticole fête cette année ses 80 ans
ensemble nous allons suivre cette route
à la découverte de monuments prestigieux
plonger dans l'histoire des cendres dans
des caves vieille de plusieurs siècles
traversée des centaines de climat
inscrit au patrimoine culturel mondial
de l'humanité
égouttez le terroir de cette terre bénie
des dieux
nous sommes sur la route des grands crus
au niveau du village de fils à cette
route des grands que d'une route
emblématique puisqu'elle elle traverse
les plus beaux villages de la côte
viticole côte-d'orienne avec des noms
tels que gevrey chambertin vosne-romanée
chambolle musigny pour la côte de nuits
ou encore pernand vergelesses montrachet
volnay morceaux pour la côte de beaune
yuri le beau et guides oenotouristique
depuis des années ils empruntent
régulièrement cette route avec ses
clients qui l'emmène visiter le vignoble
et le voilà ici dans le centre village
de gevrey chambertin
il y a neuf grands crus à
gevrey-chambertin sur les 33 que
comporte la bourgogne à ces trous des
grands crus elle est l'âme de la
bourgogne elle est celle qui nous permet
de nous tourner vers notre passé de voir
tous ces vignerons qui l'empruntent
depuis des siècles qui leur prêtent
encore aujourd'hui chaque jour pour
produire ces grands vins de bourgogne
dont on est si fier qui sont connus dans
le monde entier dès ses premiers
kilomètres la route des grands crus
plonge dans l'histoire
à la sortie de gevrey chambertin
apparaît le plus vieux clos de bourgogne
le clos de bèze
fondée en 632 par les moines de l'abbaye
du même nom un cloud est une parcelle de
vigne qu'on appelle un climat en
bourgogne est clos vient du latin claude
airs et qui veut dire fermer chaque
climat va donner à vin unique qui a un
goût qui représente la typicité du lieu
on dit vulgairement il faut que le vin
et la gueule de l'endroit où il est né
écoutez la gueule de ce gala vous avez
un vin qui est d'une grande complexité
du grande longueur en bouche mais je
crois que tout ça est finalement à
prendre avec des pincettes si vous me
permettez l'expression car le goût
personnel à chacun d'entre nous en
fonction de sa propre histoire
je dirais simplement pour citer gaston
roupnel il disait en parlant du clos de
bèze
il est tout le grand bourgogne possible
la route des grands crus est la plus
ancienne route touristique viticoles de
france
elle est née en 1937 à l'initiative du
député maire de dijon
gaston gérard
à l'époque les vignerons font face à une
crise économique sans précédent
les années 30 c'est une période de crise
crise de surproduction crise de bep
vente
mais c'est aussi une période de
renouvellement un peu du vignoble
puisqu'on à une nouvelle forme de
commercialisation et de production des
vins qui est l'appellation d'origine
l'idée c'est de réaliser une des
limitations strictes décrue pour pouvoir
mieux les vendre au 19e siècle
on n'est pas nécessairement obligés de
faire du jeu vrai chambertin avec les
raisins de gevrey-chambertin on le fait
avec des raisins de chambolle-musigny
des raisins des villages alentours
or après les appellations d'origine on a
obligation d'utiliser uniquement des
raisins de gevrey chambertin donc on a
une territorialisation du vin qui est
pas innocente et qui va créer pour
l'acheteur l'idée qu'il existe un
terroir spécifique qui donne un goût
spécifique au grain
dès lors le vignoble de bourgogne jusque
là considérée comme une simple zone de
production de raisin pour les négociants
devient lieu touristique à part entière
on vient voir le terroir au même titre
que les grands monuments historiques des
villes de dijon et beaune la route
c'est vraiment l'aboutissement de cette
construction de ce qu'on appelle le
folklore vineux on va normes et la
gastronomie régionale ça va aller avec
les vins locaux
c'est l'invention du boeuf bourguignon
des escargots de bourgogne d or murette
etc et tous ces cas là on les retrouve
dans les grandes festivités folklorique
qui se met en place dans les années 20
et 30
avec les chansons bourguignonne
également le point d'orgue de ces
festivités c'est l'invention finalement
de la confrérie des chevaliers du tas de
20 ans 1934 et 6 invention là
paradoxalement vont créer une mythologie
est une espèce d'éternité à la bourgogne
et c'est ça qui fait finalement le
succès de cette bourgogne et de cette
première route des vins en france et
l'un vante à passer avec une certaine
modernité
[Musique]
quelques kilomètres plus au sud planté
au milieu des vignes surgit un témoin
millénaire de l'histoire de la bourgogne
le château du clos de vougeot classé
monument historique
il accueille chaque année plus de 50000
visiteurs dont une bonne moitié
d'étrangers qui viennent découvrir la
longue histoire de la bourgogne viticole
leur au départ ce n'est pas un château
aussi c'est une exploitation viticole
qui est créé par les moines de cîteaux
en 11 110 et nous avons devant nous la
partie la plus ancienne encore conservé
aujourd'hui il s'agit de la grange qui
était un bâtiment multifonctions et ce
bâtiment a été construit en 170 pour
stocker le vin en particulier et à
l'étagé il y avait une grande salle qui
servait de dortoir pour accueillir les
moines de cîteaux lorsqu'ils venaient
travailler dans les vignes puis au fil
du temps le domaine s'est complétée
d'une partie château qui est la partie
renaissance qui est derrière nous
le domaine va rester petit et en 170 si
les moines obtiennent un privilège c'est
à dire que désormais ils ne paieront
plus d'impôts sur le vin qu'ils
produisent et s'assure un périmètre est
très précisément défini donc pour bien
marquer les choses dans le paysage les
moines vont décider de construire un mur
qui va entourer en fait le futur clos de
vougeot donc ce mur c'est celui qu'on
aperçoit ici c'est un mur qui fait 3 km
300 de long et qui enserre 51 hectares
de vignes et lorsqu'il est construit en
cent soixante dix les moines ne contrôle
à ce moment là que 10 hectares à
l'intérieur de ce clos et puis petit à
petit ils vont racheter ou se faire
donner progressivement l'ensemble des
terres qui se trouve à l'intérieur du
mur pour constituer un énorme domaine de
51 hectares le
clos de vougeot
[Musique]
on est à la fin du xvème siècle vers
1480 à ce moment là les moines de
cîteaux décide de construire une cuverie
de très grande dimension pour abriter
des pressoirs en période de vendanges ça
fourmille avait il y avait du monde
absolument partout chacun des pressoirs
demandait entre six et huit personnes
pour les actionner il ya quatre pressoir
ici donc il faut imaginer un ballet
incessant des par les moines produisent
pour eux mêmes mais très rapidement les
productions de vin était telle que des
moines ont commencé à commercialiser ce
vin dans les auberges des environs dans
les villes comme dijon beaune nuits
saint georges
c'était des lieux où on pouvait boire de
ce vin en 1791 le château et les vignes
sont confisqués comme biens nationaux
les vignes seront plus tard séparé est
divisé entre plusieurs propriétaires ils
sont aujourd'hui 85 à se partager
l'appellation grand cru clos vougeot qui
correspond toujours exactement au
domaine fondée par les moines
cisterciens en 1110
[Musique]
les vignerons d'aujourd'hui sont les
héritiers des moines du moyen-âge le
village de vosne-romanée tout proche du
château du clos de vougeot abrite le
domaine qui possède le plus grand nombre
de grands crus de toute la bourgogne
véritable icône de la viticulture
mondiale le domaine de la romanée conti
[Musique]
aubert de villaine cohéritiers du
domaine a porté le projet qui a abouti
en 2015
au classement des climats de bourgogne
au patrimoine culturel mondial de
l'humanité
nous sommes ici en plein coeur parce
qu'on appelle un climat en bourgogne
c'est la romanée-conti ses limites
voulez vous les voyez cette limite de ce
petit mur ici le mur là bas ces zigzags
vers vous voyez là et la petite route en
terre qui est là bas juste à côté de la
croix un climat c'est ça c'est un vin
c'est une une parcelle de vigne qui est
qui a une certaine superficie des
limites qui sont inscrites dans le
marbre des appellations qui a un nom et
qui fait un vin qui a un goût spécifique
particulier que les amateurs reconnaît
ses recherches
la plupart des plus grands vins en
bourgogne se trouve dans cette dans ce
secteur de la côte où la pente s'amortit
et devient non pas plate mais avec une
pente très douce l'armée les conti elle
elle est en plein milieu de ce secteur
privilégié et c'est certainement une des
raisons de la qualité du vin en obtenant
la reconnaissance de l'unesco
aubert de villaine a voulu préserver cet
héritage précieux et fragile laissés par
les générations passées
et regardez aujourd'hui comme un modèle
au niveau mondial
[Musique]
ici nous sommes dans une cave d'élevage
qui est très ancienne typique des cas
venez le âge en bourgogne dans une
philosophie le climat de terroir d'une
viticulture de terroir tous les
vignerons se rejoignent pour dire qu'il
faut faire un élevage qui soient le
moins interventionniste possible comme
on dit c'est à dire qu'ils qui laisse
aux vins la capacité de se développer
comme il l'entend il est difficile
d'être simple mais je pense que c'est
vraiment la clé pour faire des des très
grands vins c'est la simplicité au
niveau de la vinification
comme au niveau de l'élevage
[Musique]
les grands crus comme ceux élevés dans
ces fûts représente 1% de la production
totale de la bourgogne
cette rareté explique en partie les prix
vertigineux atteints par certaines
bouteilles dont celle de la romanée
conti vendus plus de 1500 euros la
bouteille à des clients triés sur le
volet je peux vous risquez une petite
anecdote à l'époque où le futur
président du brésil
le fameux lula faisait sa campagne j'ai
reçu un coup de fil d'un journaliste
brésilien qui me demandait ce que vous
savez que les partisans de lula ont créé
un site internet qui s'appelle romanée
conti para todos cueilli romanée conti
pour tous
et pourquoi pas 10 parce que le a été vu
dans un restaurant buvant elle peut-être
mais les conti ses adversaires ont dit
mais comment ce qu'un candidat
socialiste peut voir l'armée conti donc
ses partisans dit nous ce qu'on veut
c'est pas que tout le monde soit peau de
long 2 soit riche et boivent l'armée
quand il m'a demandé mais qu'est ce que
vous en pensez
j'avais dit que tu es qu à penser qu'on
peut faire en tout et pour tout que 6000
bouteilles maximum daumas et conti donc
n aura jamais pour tous suivre la route
des grands crus
c'est aussi prendre son temps musarder
au bord des vignes est l'occasion de
goûter à la gastronomie locale
mathieu mazoyer est un enfant du pays il
y à 13 ans il a installé son restaurant
le millésime dans le village de
chambolle musigny en plein coeur de la
route des grands crus un endroit
stratégique
même si sa cuisine se permet parfois des
incartades avec la tradition
bourguignonne vous descendez au petit
show les asperges blanches vous plaît
allez hop & sand et sam est et sera bien
dans de l'eau
moi ce que j'adore cuisiner c'est le
cochon à la le cochon de a à z du du
moins jusqu'à là que les pieds aussi ça
permet de faire découvrir aux gens des
choses qu'on cuisine puce
ou qu'on n'a pas l'habitude de cuisiner
on va dire mais est-ce que cuisiner avec
des grands crus cela demande un soin
particulier
il faut surtout faire attention de pas
voir des ports des plaques qui puisse
envahir trop loin on va dire trop trop
prendre le dessus par rapport aux vins
surtout comme un vin comme
chambolle-musigny c'est un vin qui est
quand même sur la finesse
bon faut toujours faire attention à ce
genre de choses me reste quelques
bouteilles et après je suis en place un
petit coup de main le restaurant de
mathieu possède l'une des plus belles
cartes de grands crus de la route
mais pour damien gelot son sommelier la
partie n'est pas toujours facile alors
être au coeur de la route des grands
crus
c'est un avantage qui fait qu'il ya
énormément de passage mais de très
grands amateurs de vin ce qui peut aussi
être une certaine pression puisqu'ils
ont des attentes assez précise
d'où les 650 références sur la carte
permanente tout en essayant de
l'enrichir tous les ans de 10 à 20
références supplémentaires
c'est jamais facile d'avoir des grands
crus c'est une production qui est très
petit demandé dans le monde entier
c'est un long travail de confiance aussi
avec les viticulteurs mais c'est
toujours en petite quantité pour
certaines par trois pour d'autres
seulement par une bouteille par an donc
non non c'est pas plus facile pour nous
que pour nos voisins de bonou ou de
chablis pour avoir ses grands crus c'est
l'armoire trésor et puisque on peut y
voir certains grands crus de la
bourgogne bien sûr pas tous mon préféré
de vosne-romanée on ne présente plus
aujourd'hui
qui est tout simplement la romanée-conti
n'en a pas tous les ans on en a une tous
les trois ans je pense qu'on aura
peut-être la chance d'en avoir une
seconde cette année
pour vous donner un ordre d'idée cette
bouteille sur la carte avoisine les dix
mille euros
là vous emmener deux carpaccio j en sais
pas chez de saint jacques qui a pas deux
asperges
allez hop on y va le brocoli on y va
aussi
allez on y va pour les du carpaccio à
les emmener en y emmener
à mi-parcours de son trajet la route des
grands crus abandonne la côte de nuits
ces crus rouges légendaire et son pinot
noir pour entrer dans la côte de beaune
presque exclusivement dédié au vin blanc
et au chardonnay bonne capitale des vins
de bourgogne regorge de monuments
historiques datant du moyen-âge dont les
célèbres hospices de beaune
pour youri le beau le monument
représente une étape incontournable
nous nous trouvons au centre de l'hôtel
dieu qui fait partie des hospices de
beaune et qui a été créé en 1443 par le
chancelier du duc de bourgogne philippe
lebon ce chancelier n'était autre que
nicolas rolin nicolas rolin décide de
créer un hôpital
nous sommes à la fin de la guerre de
cent ans et trois quarts de la
population bernoise est formé
d'indigents on va non seulement soigner
ces personnes mais aussi et surtout les
nourrir c'est dans cette cour où toi
vernissée et dans la salle des pôvres
tout proche ont été tournées en 1966
quelques unes des scènes cultes du film
la grande vadrouille qui fut longtemps
le plus gros succès du cinéma français
alors nous voilà ici au coeur de la
salle des pour c'est dans cette salle
qui était soigné les malades à l'hôtel
dieu
les dimensions cette salle sont
exceptionnels
46 mètres de long 14 m de large et
surtout seize mètres de hauteur
l'ensemble des lits de part et d'autres
étaient dirigés en direction de cette
chapelle ce qui permettait aux malades
de participer aux offices religieux
[Musique]
beaune abrite de nombreux monuments
médiévaux prestigieux mais une partie de
ces trésors se cache aussi sous terre
véronique drouet responsable de la
vinification et de l'élevage des vins de
la maison du même nom est l'héritière
d'un patrimoine architectural souterrain
exceptionnel alors nous nous trouvons
dans l'ancienne cuverie de la collégiale
notre dame donc un bâtiment du xiiie
siècle contemporain de l'église dont
construit fin de 12e débuts 13e donc
c'était le lieu de travail des moines
qui est ici qu'ils aient leurs vins il
avait un joli patrimoine viticole et
donc il a besoin d'un endroit pour
vinifier donc la prière et le travail se
faisait ici derrière moi un magnifique
vestiges du 16e siècle ce pressoir dit à
perroquet donc c'est un pressoir qui on
pense servi environ 200 ans
et puis en 1980 où l'on perd a eu cette
idée de remettre en activité ce pressoir
qui avait été en sommeil pendant 200 ans
le système est très ingénieux et très
simple très efficace et ne requiert
aucune électricité en tournant cette rue
voilà il ya leur suppression a chanté
craque c'est magnifique
donc la roue tourne et fait descendre
cette poutre principale qu'on appelle un
bouton qui vient presser les raisins qui
au préalable évidemment ont été posées
sur ce plateau et sur lesquels on a mis
ses planchers ces poutres et donc en
abaissant cette grosse poutre va presser
le juge va s'écouler retomber si le jus
qu'on va mettre en fuite
et quand on imagine l'âge de ces bois
avec le pressoir et de 15 cents soixante
dix mais si on veut par exemple apôtres
qui est là haut
l'arbre qui était duchesne devait avoir
environ 300 ans donc on imagine bien
qu'une partie des pièces de ce pressoir
à peut-être connu charlemagne
maintenant nous nous trouvons sous le
vieux pressoir dans la cave du treizième
alors cédé très vieille cave de la ville
de beaune
donc c'est ici que les chanoines élevait
leurs vins donc ils entonnaient mettez
en sus et puis les vins rester ici
jusqu'à jusqu'à la mise alors pas en
bouteille à l'époque mais je pense que
la consommation était quand même assez
rapide
à l'époque des moines et puis avait pas
de commercialisation des vins c'était
très très bonne cave d'élevage elles
sont toujours à température assez égal
elles ont une humidité parfaite
il n'y a pas de métro ya pas de tram
dont il ya aucune vibration dans ces cas
là c'est très serein
moi je trouve qu'on a la chance de
travailler avec multiplicité de terroir
c'est un peu le mystère et la complexité
la bourgogne mais en même temps pour
nous c'est un travail extraordinaire que
d'essayer de révéler chacun de ses
terroirs puisque voilà on parle de nos
climats de non-lieu 10 chacun de ces
vins représentent une petite entité donc
c'est vrai que notre travail
au fond c'est d'apprendre seclinois mais
ça prend une vie on les connaît même pas
tous à la fin de notre vie mais à force
de déguster et de parler aux anciens à
ceux qui ont l'expérience oublions
vinifier on va apprendre que bâle bonne
grève voilà la caractéristique d'un boni
grève c'est vrai un petit peu structuré
on va déguster le corton charlemagne
malgré le fait que le vent soit jeunes
on a déjà une complexité aromatique qui
n'est pas juste sur un fruit ou une
fleur et ça c'est un petit peu la raison
de cette classification de nouvelles
bourgogne se dire qu'un bourgogne
délicieux trêve très fruité très
fringant mais peut-être un petit peu
mono dimensionnelles et là quand on va
monter dans la hiérarchie c'est à dire
vers les premiers et les grands crus
on va avoir une palette aromatique
beaucoup plus complexe c'est la raison
pour laquelle ses vignes là ont été
classés en grands crus parce que c'est
pas juste cette année mais c'était il ya
dix ans il
il ya cent ans il ya mille ans quand les
moines ont commencé en fait à délimiter
les zones qu'ils estiment être les
meilleurs il y avait déjà cette
complexité dans les 20 à la sortie de
bonnes
nous avons abandonné temporairement
notre traction pour une balade à vélo à
travers les vignes un moyen ludique
légèrement sportif est totalement écolo
de partir à la découverte des villages
emblématiques de la cote comme pommard
volnay ou meursault et de profiter du
paysage garder on va vers la petite
qu'abbott un refuge de vignerons une
garçonnière tu pouvais faire
vous faites attention parce que là il
faut pas se cogner la tête allez-y as
une capote à peu près de 300 bon c'est
pas trop datés voire plus c'est que de
la pierre sèche et donc c'était utiliser
bas pour faire un petit break quand il
pleut quand il fait chaud vignerons
étaient heureux de s'arrêter ici et puis
également
ça permettait de stocker un petit peu de
matériel à l'écloserie si vous imaginez
cette frange semaine absorbent la
chaleur qui restitue et pendant la nuit
avec du coup ça donne une espèce de
micro atmosphère au sein du club la
maturation du raisin est meilleur dans
un clos
[Musique]
faire une pause on fait du vélo on
découvre le vignoble et surtout c'est
aussi souvent pour ça que les gens
viennent on va déguster du vin on visite
les caves on visite la cuverie donc ça
permet d'avoir une vision assez globale
de la bourgogne puisqu'on voit les
choses d'une manière beaucoup plus
explicites on a le temps de s'arrêter de
sentir de voir on a beaucoup de
clientèle étrangère à clientèle
américaine qui adore ce genre
d'activités on a les canadiens les
australiens les asiatiques viennent les
européens sont là et le vélo pour moi
s'est imposé comme le moyen idéal
voilà donc je vous invite à venir
prendre un verre
voilà
à la baule
[Musique]
la dernière portion de la route des
grands crus réserve encore un ultime
trésor de la bourgogne viticole
ici nous sommes au coeur du triangle
d'or lorsque l'on parle du triangle d'or
on parle des plus grands vins blancs
secs du monde avec notamment
l'emblématique montrachet qui se trouve
entre trois villages à l'intersection de
trois villages le village de meursault
au nord du triangle d'or puligny
montrachet et aussi chassagne montrachet
le montrachet dont alexandre dumas
disait qu'il fallait le boire à genoux
et la tête découverte appartient à
l'élite des plus grands vins blancs du
monde
ceva inaccessible produit en très petite
quantité est recherché par la terre
entière
les sept hectares 99 qui le produisent
sont presque devenu un lieu de
pèlerinage des touristes qu'ils viennent
de l'hexagone où qu ils viennent du
monde entier
quand ils ont eu la chance de traverser
les villages dont ils ont entendu parler
tant de fois quand ils ont eu la chance
de sillonner les vignes
de les caresser du regard de déguster
les vins de pénétrer dans les caves tout
ça participe aux souvenirs qu'il faut en
avoir et lorsqu'ils rentrent une déguste
de plus des vannes bourgogne mets
dégustés par celle de souvenirs notre
voyage aussi se termine ici près du
petit village de santenay le coffre les
yeux et la bouche remplie de souvenirs
avec une envie folle de revenir bientôt
et oui et nos grands vins sont aussi
briller les yeux des touristes qui
empruntent nos routes chaque année ils
sont mauvais c'est là c'est terminé pour
aujourd'hui je vous donne rendez vous la
semaine prochaine
d'ici là je vous embrasse et restons
connectés